dort sitzen die leute ganz kurz weil
sicherlich in den kommentaren stehen
wird wir sehen für dich dein
hochzeitskleider aus oder das rote
zumindest ist absolut keine
hochzeitskleid ich habe einfach
hochzeitskleider eingegeben das hier war
das erste das rote ist auch irgendwo
hier und hab dich halt einfach bestellt
ob das jetzt zu 100 prozent
hochzeitskleider sind oder nicht weil
sie nicht
hey leute was geht ab und jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video sollte
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's gut ich
hoffe dir jetzt auch gut aber bestimmt
nicht
jawohl vor ungefähr zwei wochen haben
wir das video gemacht wo ich marie
einige wie soll ich sagen war das
nochmal genau halt so kleider gekauft
habe und meist das halt gemacht habe
euch direkt hochzeit ist er damit
bestellt wollte ich schon immer mal
machen ich habe hier irgendwann mal über
aliexpress bestellt ich weiß nicht ob er
das kennt das problem ist die sind
irgendwie nie angekommen ich glaube 1
ist angekommen und zwar nicht und dann
musste ich da auch irgendein video zu
drehen aber jetzt haben wir hier neue
pakete erhalten was macht reinigen die
sind voll kleinen das decken sowie
wasser einfach selbst an bevor du jetzt
hier die kleider anziehst ich sehe auch
irgend ein bisschen als oder oder was
sagst du wenn du willst vielleicht so
hofft selbst daran hast muss ich ja auch
irgendwie ein bisschen
hier hat gut aus so gut oder so dann
möchte ich auch gar nicht lange um den
heißen brei herum schnacken und würde
sagen wir fangen direkt mal an das sieht
echt gut aus
ich glaube ich sollte öfter so was
tragen also gib mir doch mal bitte das
erste paket
da ist es richtig klein nein es ist
nicht klein dass durch also natürlich
ist das jetzt kein hort kleid was so
fünf meter lang ist ich glaube die
gibt's doch gar nicht habe ich gar nicht
gefunden ich habe einfach hochzeitskleid
angeblich und kleider die bisschen
freuen immer aus sondern davon welche
bestellt und dass ich jetzt jetzt jetzt
erst nicht einfach nicht rein
sie stinken gar nicht so sehr wow wow
wow das sieht richtig gut aus oder aber
ich glaube an
guck mal da sind sogar so baxmann ist
das nicht durchsichtig ist heraus sind
das für patch für mich schon mal gar
nicht so schlecht oder
ich denke auch gar nicht so dass leute
das hier ist das nächste paket
ich weiß gar nicht ich hab nämlich auch
noch was woanders gestellt vielleicht
ist das jetzt gar nicht nur noch
zeitgleich bestimmten anlässen wie sie
oder
aber das ist echt ein kleid
ja ich habe es jetzt hier gibt es jetzt
auch verstand ich dachte zuerst dass
personen um haben so ein verkleinerter
sie haben das sieht heftig aus da habe
ich aber richtig gute sachen bestellt
oder also ich meine das hat heute mache
ich dachte zuerst es wären königin
umhang oder sohn beim proben hang
ich glaube das muss man hier oben im
nacken zusammen nennt man muss auch
sagen wer spaß hat mich ganze neun euro
gekostet also dieses ding hier und das
ist aber wirklich lecker das ist ein
richtiger schlag hinter dir dann ist das
ja auch klar das ist nämlich von auf das
von jugend und blödsinn
das hier ist aber ein kleid leute das
ist mit erbsen personen geraten stellt
ich habe mich als ich dir diese
kardashian keiner stelle habe ich auch
noch zwei von jugend gestellt weil du
bist ja so die konkurrenz seite von
nuance besser ist und dann einfach mal
so zu gucken was besser ist ja dass mehr
pakete haben als auch wenn ich finde aus
oder eigentlich der hingucker hat das
video sollte es ja du werden aber ich
glaube jetzt bin ich schon oder hier mit
meinem anzug sieht aus wie dieses h2o
plötzlich meerjungfrau also david wird
jetzt nur noch seine flosse fehlen weiß
ja ich finde damit könntest du so in
seinem alter film mitspielen oder
deutlich baumax hier oben und dann haben
wir hier so ein bisschen dass man das
halt auch sehen kann
leute das hier nämlich daran auf dass
hier ist das erste kleid hat mich elf
euro kostet hab ich glaube ich auch
schon gesagt also hier ist keine person
die das trägt das sieht einfach so aus
komplett in ja eigentlich die das ja er
weiß aus ist ein echt aber deutlich
goldener eigentlich finde ich sehr
komisch haben hier vier bewertungen die
alle einen stern sind also keine ahnung
warum aber gut war den meisten wohl
irgendwie zu groß schaut selbst wie es
bei uns außer
wir kürzen sollten wir hier am mikrofon
so was meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren liebe kinder und jugendliche
herzlich willkommen zur miss germany
2009 himmel begrüßen wir unsere erste
kandidatin mit einem bezaubernden
goldenen kleid
die hitze macht marie seine leute dieses
kleid ist eigentlich echt süß ist auch
vor allen dingen von st aber das macht
dir hast du ja meistens die beste figur
sei es natürlich noch mal auf den stuhl
damit die leute aussehen können wir das
weil das tier fest jetzt springen einmal
hoch meine frage ist doch nicht wo ich
heute das kleine live irgendeiner musste
aber ich muss ja sagen ich finde meine
angst oder noch besser und das kleid
sieht es als schwanger
vielleicht ist ja schon aber das heißt
folgt schön eigentlich oder so leute
jetzt habe ich noch ein zweites kleid
bestellt was laut mario okay kann ich
auch selber so akzeptieren dass hier ist
das nächste kleid ich hab das dann rot
gewählt hat im neuen euro kostet jetzt
kostet irgendwie 10 kommt auch ganz gut
bei den leuten an wir haben vier sterne
bewertungen also die meisten waren
glaube ich echt zufrieden sehr schönes
material und tolle farbe das kleid ist
super qualität und form super musste ich
eigentlich auch sagen also schlecht war
es auf keinen fall gab es da noch einer
anderen farbe ich habe dann einfach rot
genommen und wie das aussah das sieht
jetzt ist wohl kein richtiges
hochzeitskleid oder einfach ein ganz
normales kleid was aber auch nur 9 euro
gekostet hat ist ja nicht die welt nicht
persönlich aber auch ganz gut ihr könnt
ja mal wieder in die kommentare
schreiben welches am besten findet und
bitteschön hallo du möchte neben dem
tanzen kannst jetzt besser aus oder das
andere
ich glaube das habe ich meinen habe ich
das richtig gut
also so ist das auf den autor ihr
größtes noch so ist das auch von
originalen bildern gebunden
ja ne ist ganz okay oder also ich weiß
nicht was auch so dazu ich bin ja ich
finde die sind beide vom schritt
eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht über
die machen balkan figur die etwas haut
ja wird weil das hängt ja also ich sag
ja nicht nur neun euro kosten
ich finde die für alle nicht findet dass
also das finde ich halt kann man nicht
viel falsch machen und das finde ich
eigentlich recht folgen verarbeitet
dafür das ist also das hat es gekostet
euro also dass andere kleid noch mal
kurz hier ein foto was wir eben hatten
das fand ich wirklich echt gut so das
kann man auch oder können würde ich
jetzt sagen so wenn ihr ein kleid sucht
für ich weiß nich abschluss fallen von
eurem geschwistern und noch kein kleid
habe und nur 11 euro ausgeben wollt dann
ist das auf jeden fall eine gute option
ja da sind ja heute leider hatten wir
heute nur zwei kleider einfach weil ich
kein drittes bestellt habe ich weiß
nicht warum aber ist halt so vielleicht
hätte namen hast du jetzt nicht weiter
doch klar der ist doch genau so schick
wie kleider aber der ist so von jugend
leute ein kleid haben wir noch das ist
jetzt zwar nicht von mensch sondern von
jun aber wir probieren das einfach mal
mit an wenn wir schon dabei sind so und
um das jetzt auch noch mit ins video zu
nehmen habe ich das noch bestellt das
ist jetzt auch schon länger her ich weiß
dass kein hochzeitskleid aber haben wir
einfach mit reingenommen hat zehn euro
gekostet ist diesmal von jugend wollte
ich in zukunft öfter sachen bestellen
allerdings gefällt mir da nicht so viel
oder bei vielen sachen wenn ich mir so
ja ist jetzt irgendwie ja nichts
besonderes wie das außer in echt schaut
selbst viel spaß sollte das letzte
kleinod diesmal ganz wichtig war von
jugend nicht von mischa bitteschön
das ist aber ein overall
ach ja also keinen kleinteile das sieht
so aus wie kennst du jeden posten will
jedes jahr was anderes nein das sieht
aus wie diese images diese zwillingspaar
suncatcher macht diese beiden ballerinas
was mit dem video drei kleider ich finde
die schneiden alle ganz gut drauf aber
das wurde das hat mir jetzt nicht so
gefallen ich bin nach die qualität hier
fand diesem jugend besser ist die
qualität
wir stehen ja nicht so als wären wir
gleich beim ok wenn sie heiraten über
lernen würde ich glaube ich aus der
kirche heraus also schreibt er gerne
weil ich es euch am meisten gefallen hat
dann kann ich jetzt auch wieder dieses
dingen hier ausziehen ich glaube das
muss ich jetzt elfter anziehen
also leute haut rein das video wird
irgendwie so ein bisschen chaotisch aber
so ist das manchmal steckt ja noch
unsere instagram kanäle ab und sollte
diesmal nicht so gemeint sorry